so uh yesterday there was a um a press
briefing from Nashville PD after the
shooting at the Covenant School this
horrible event in which six people were
killed and the shooter also died and a
parent was actually able to get on air
which was fantastic and as The Daily
Beast writes a mother visiting Nashville
took to the Fox News Airwaves to call
out the country's lack of gun safety as
yet another mass shooting unfolded at a
Nashville school this was as reporters
and Crews were waiting for a police
press conference to start the woman has
been identified by local reporters as
Ashby Beasley
who herself survived the July 4 parade
in Highland Park Illinois and was a
block away from the Covenant School
yesterday here she is jumping in and
this is uh take a listen aren't you guys
tired of covering this aren't you guys
tired of being here and having to cover
all of these mass shootings I'm from
Highland Park
the audio briefly cuts out but then it
comes back
family vacation with my son visiting my
sister-in-law I have been lobbying in DC
since we survived a mass shooting in
July I have met with over 130 lawmakers
how is this still happening how are our
children still dying and why are we
failing them gun violence is the number
one killer of children and teens it has
overtaken cars assault weapons are
contributing to the Border crisis and
Fentanyl we are arming cartels with our
guns and our Goose loose gun laws and
these shootings in these mass shootings
will continue to happen until our
lawmakers step up and pass gun safety
legislation yeah but instead they want
to pass laws about critical race Theory
books that need to be banned art that
needs to be banned history that can't be
taught sex education that can't be
taught they want to do everything other
than actually deal with what is at issue
here I'm pretty sure this was an
unsecured weapon that this teenager got
a hold of we can't even pass gun safe to
like say storage laws in this country to
protect kids from getting a hold of
weapons that they shoot each other with
all right so uh we're gonna break away
there because that reporter who was
using that camera is uh obviously
setting up to do a live report there but
the woman
said it quite so simply aren't you tired
of this yes we are tired of this yeah of
course most of Fox News disagrees with
what needs to be done in order to try to
resolve the situation good for her
sounds weird to say right place right
time because the the right place is not
really being a block away from a
shooting that's extremely dangerous but
the right place right time to at least
get that out on national television and
absolutely good for her they want to ban
all sorts of stuff but it's all the
wrong things and we're going to continue
covering it we'll take a break and be
back with plenty more right after this
one of our sponsors is Helix sleep I
have been sleeping on a helix mattress
at home for years now I couldn't be more
happy with it I recommend it to
everybody the other day even though
she's not allowed in the big bed I put
my baby daughter on the mattress and
even she loved it Helix sleep is the
premium mattress brand offering tailored
mattresses based on your unique sleep
preferences take the Helix sleep quiz it
asks you about your body type your
sleeping position do you get hot at
night do you have back pain and then
Helix will match you with the mattress
that's perfect for you most people don't
know where to begin when shopping for a
mattress including me Helix makes it
simple and less risky because you know
you're getting a mattress that fits your
needs it ships free you can try it for a
hundred nights to see if you like it and
it comes with a 10 or 15 year warranty
unlike many mattress companies all Helix
mattresses are made in the USA by a
skilled production team so you are
supporting good jobs Helix sleep is
giving my audience up to 20 percent off
plus two free pillows what other
mattress company is going to give you 20
off go to helixsleep.com Pacman the link
is down below